A $1.6 billion lawsuit against Fox News
is shedding
damaging light
on what people at the network
really thought about Donald Trump
and his baseless election.
Fraud claims
and private text messages
between Fox personalities.
They express real doubts about any notion
the election was stolen
while they went on to promote
the president's lies on the air.
In a statement,
Fox says The core of this case
remains about freedom of the press,
freedom of speech,
which are fundamental rights
afforded by the Constitution.
And joining us now to talk about
this is Floyd Abrams.
He's one of the most renowned
First Amendment attorneys in the past
50 years, he's
been involved in
decisions from the Pentagon Papers
to the Citizens United ruling.
And Floyd
it's a pleasure to have you here.
Thanks so much for joining us.
You've said that
the revelations in this case are a
major blow to Fox. They're
talking about the First Amendment.
Do they have a leg to stand on?
They've got a real tough case.
I mean,
journalists get a lot of protection,
as you well know.
And
that's especially
so when they talk about,
you know, matters of public interest.
And one of the major problems here
is that
they had people on the air again
and again and again
who are saying that these voting machines
were phony, that they were built
for fraud.
That they were purposely created
And at the same time and right after
those things are being said, more senior
people at Fox are saying,
the person that's saying that is a liar.
I know she's a liar.
She lied to me.
And and similar statements,
one statement by a very
senior on air person,
which was exactly the same thing.
But it was that
that person's a complete nut and right.
That person is back
again and again on the air.
So it makes it very difficult,
maybe not impossible,
but really difficult for Fox to defend
on the ground that.
Well,
we're just journalists
interviewing people.
Well, in case in point,
I mean, this wasn't
just about saving face,
but saving the network
that pays their bills. On November 12.
2021 reporter over at Fox
was pushing back on a Trump
tweet claiming
that Dominion had deleted
or switch millions of votes Trump votes.
And we have this tweet up on screen
saying there was no evidence
that any voting system deleted
or lost votes, changed votes
or was in any way compromised.
But then, as you know,
Floyd Tucker Carlson
erupted in a private
message to Sean Hannity saying, please
get her fired.
Seriously, what the EFF
I'm actually shocked at needs
to stop immediately.
Like tonight, it's
measurably hurting the company.
What do these kinds of private messages
show, do you think?
Well,
first of all, it's
really unusual for a libel plaintiff
to be able
to get their hands on messages like this
because they are so inculpatory that they
they sell threaten the ability
of of the broadcast company
afterwards to say, well, look,
we're just interviewing something
we believe.
And we don't know what's true
with just looking for the facts.
If they're saying to each other
at the same time,
you know, that person's and not
it makes it
very hard, maybe not impossible.
I mean, no, no, but but it makes it
an unusual case
to because evidence of that really
rarely comes up in a libel case.
It's extraordinary
to see behind the curtain
in this instance.
And here's another example
from November 18th.
2020.
Tucker
Carlson and Laura Ingraham privately
reacting to these outrageous
claims made by Trump adviser
Sidney Powell. Carlson, Tech City.
Powell is lying, by the way.
I caught her.
It's insane, Ingraham responds.
Sidney is a complete night.
No one will work with her.
Ditto with Rudy.
Carlson continues,
Our viewers are good people.
They believe it.
And then Fox kept
putting Sidney Powell on the air
to spout these outrageous lies.
Floyd, that's your viewers.
Exactly. Yeah.
Does that mean they defamed Dominion
was clear that they defamed
they legal question is, can they say
we believed it?
And so far as I know,
no one from Fox has come forward
even even in the course of a lawsuit
and said, oh, yeah,
that that's what we believe.
We we I myself really believed
that that
these voting machines were fraudulent.
So there's none of the validation
that that occurs so often.
In libel cases.
And instead, Fox is left with a situation
where they have people on repeatedly
saying defamatory things
about this company and another company
that makes the voting machines
and at the same time, the,
the the offensive things are being said.
At the same time,
people are saying,
you know,
these machines don't work on purpose.
That's fraud.
At that very moment, people from Fox,
you gave examples of saying, oh, yeah,
I know that person's a liar,
and then they invite her back again.
Well, I have to ask a real problem.
Yeah.
And and I suppose Dominion could argue
that they have been damaged
in all of this because, I mean,
there are just so many people
on the right side
of the political spectrum
who will just never
you may never believe a
Dominion voting system,
you know, election in the future
that they've been a part of.
Isn't that I mean, isn't
that something
that they're talking about?
Yeah.
And yeah, I mean, when when entities,
when cities, when states
want to purchase voting machines
are they're going
to take account of the fact.
And why would they not take account
of the fact
that that you know,
on a major network in America,
there were repeated statements
that those voting machines
were fraudulent.
So that's that's why
the revelation
and the brief filed
by by Dominion
that that I mean,
all these people were saying
that's not true,
that this person is not to be trusted.
That person who they have
on, again, is not to be trusted.
That that's very damaging to Fox's case.
And Floyd,
I have to ask
you, because Fox has been such a
monumental presence
in American news media for so many years,
if Dominion
were to be ultimately successful
in all of this
and Fox
were to have to
pay this kind of huge penalty,
what would that do to Fox?
What would that do to
I guess right wing media in this country?
Would it would it force, do you think,
some of these folks
on the right,
maybe on all sides
of the political spectrum
to be more careful
with the facts,
be more careful with the truth?
You know, I don't want to dodge
the question.
It's just so hard to know
and especially it's hard
because so many people have already
been so persuaded by Fox
and the pretty far right media entities
about essentially corruption
of everyone else but them that I'm
not sure
they are going to lose their audience.
Or if they do that,
it won't go to another
very far right wing entity.
We just can't tell.
What we can tell is that
this is an unusually highly unusually
threatening lawsuit
against a major, major media entity.